fresh hot burgers sexy burgers she's not  with us shoo shoo not bob this memorial  day big things are coming for summertina  if you want to catch us you'll have to  take off those bulky jeans uh to be more  aerodynamic oh you're doing it already  great big things like that heat rash you  get sometimes tigger it's bigger  what the it's meteor  that feels nice it's coming to the big  screen  holy smoke is crazy totally  how about  what just the gasp is great thank you  like this  i think we got it the last one was good  [Music]  happy  not what i was expecting  the bob's burgers movie pdpg 13. i'm the  marketing department i took gene's  burger suit let out the crotch a little  bit and bam a burger with a bikini on it  oh yeah  only peter's may 27th  [Music]